étranger
[Musique]
fais-le faire ça nous rend
meilleurs
plus vite plus fort
[Musique]
mieux plus vite plus fort
[Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Applaudissements]
rires
[Musique] [Applaudissements]
étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Musique] [Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Applaudissements] [Musique] [Applaudissements] [
Musique]
étranger
allez
[Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
tous les jours
[Musique]
tu bouges tu m'as mis à l'entraînement
étrangère [Musique
] c'est
vrai [
Musique] [
Musique]
encore une fois [
rit [
Musique]
[Musique]
[  Musique]
laisse-moi entendre cette merde
étrangère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
ok
[Musique]
J'ai eu ce sentiment le jour d'été
quand tu étais parti, j'ai écrasé ma voiture sur
le pont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
Je l'adore
[Musique]
incroyable
étrangère [
Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
merci bébé
[Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Musique]
ça descend
[Musique]
merci  vous
étranger
[Musique]
cinq personnes les rêves
et allons-y
étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
devinez qui est de retour
restez
toujours à faire ça
[Musique]
étranger
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je remercie  ma
chère, À maintes reprises,
j'ai purgé ma peine
mais je n'ai commis aucun crime
ni de mauvaises erreurs
Je t'ai fait sentir que
j'avais moi-même
[Musique]
champions mes amis
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Musique]
étrangère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et tout le monde la regarde mais elle a l'air
bien
[Musique]
étrangère
et ils restent là et ils disent ouais
et ils disent ouais et ils disent ouais
[Musique]
Hallelujah
[Musique] [
Musique]
reculez l'
équipe de DJ du New Jersey ce que nous faisons
[Musique]
beaucoup [
Musique]
[Musique]
étrangère
merci de
revenir plus tard
[Musique]
merci